euh on va passer à l'autre buz du jour
avant de d'accueillir Baya Carla euh oui
c'est c'est pas une danse de l'été c'est
c'est une chroniqueuse de de face à Nuna
euh parce qu'on a on a retrouvé des ils
ont retrouvé donc vous savez que en fait
elle a été plein de fois en télé et le
seul la seule fois où est chroniqueux
chez nous il y a plein de choses qui
ressortent sur son facebook et cetera ce
qui prouve le succès de l'émission
d'ailleurs merci à vous hein parce que
céta plus de 900000 déjà hier en 2 jours
c'est déjà énorme et euh B Carla standal
euh elle est dans la tourmente après la
révélation d'un ancien compte facebook
elle va s'expliquer dans TPMP alors
est-ce que c'est son compte est-ce que
c'est pas son compte euh vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez ici bien
entendu autour de la table elle vient
avec son avocat Maître Bernard
bernhim qui sera là regardez petit
reccap et on en parle juste après et
encore merci Monsieur le Maire vous
rentrez là direct là merci à tous vous
rentrez direct là sur Direct direct
absolument vous rentrez pas en SUV hein
pas de c pas de cavi vous êtes pas garé
on SUV toute façon là on est à Boulogne
heureusement ça passe encore
regardez
ce weekend cyril hanuna a lancé face à
hanuna une nouvelle émission diffusée le
samedi et le
dimanche et parmi les chroniqueurs qui
composent ces deux nouveaux rendez-vous
les téléspectateurs ont pu découvrir
Baya Carla Stendal je su très heureuse
d'être là merci beaucoup merci mais
cette influenceuse d'extrême droite
soutient d'éc Zemour est aujourd'hui
dans la tourmente rattrapé par un ancien
compte Facebook sur lequel figure
notamment cette photo datée de 2012 où
l'on peut voir un enfant marcher sur un
drapeau israélien arme à la main alors
le compte facebook lui appartient-il ba
à Carla Stendal s'explique dans tes
PMP merci ba à Carla d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir vous êtes avec moi donc
dans face à Nouna et merci Maître d'être
avec nous donc c'est vous avez déjà pris
un avocat Maître Bernard
benayem donc cette histoire
racontez-nous parce qu'on a vu plein de
choses Gill déjà est-ce que tu peux nous
résumer oui donc B carla est une
chroniqueuse qui se veut disons d'une
droite dure à assumé et là des
publications d'un compte facebook qui
date de 2012 ont montré des clichés sur
lesquels on voit effectivement qu'elle
est proalestinienne c'est-à-dire qu'un
enfant armé piétine le drapeau israélien
c'est un renversement des valeurs qui
est saisissant et qui a été dénoncé par
des gens sur les réseaux sociaux et
ailleurs qui estiment que ce compte
facebook selon eux c'est bien un compte
facebook qui vous appartient que ce
compte facebook traduit l'hypocrisie en
quelque sorte de bayak Carla voilà euh
d'accord alors Bay Carla merci d'être là
euh c'est quoi donc cette histoire de
compte facebook bah écoutez je me suis
réveillé ce matin en découvrant tout
tous ces tweets euh qui qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être car ce n'est pas moi voilà
je je le dis de devant devant tout le
monde ce n'est pas moi euh mes parents
m'ont transmis un héritage catholique et
français que je défends et j'ai à cœur
de de les transmettre j'ai j'ai à cœur
de de défendre l'amour de mon pays la
France de toujours et qui innove et
surtout la la France qui s'exprime
librement et c'est pour pour ça qu'il ne
me feront pas terre parce que c'est tout
là l'objectif de de mes détracteurs
alors les photos datent de 2012 donc il
y a 12 ans vous avez 23 ans aujourd'hui
24 ou 2 24 donc vous aviez 12 ans donc
ça voilà 11 ans 12 ans
euh donc pour vous c'est comment ça se
fait que c'est ressorti ça et comment ça
se fait que on dit que c'est où bah je
sais que mon intervention face à Hamza
n'a pas plu hein je pense alors vous
savez quoi on avait d'ailleurs on avait
l'extrait c'est Hamza après après voilà
c'est quoi c'est c'est ce jeune homme
qui a été discriminé selon lui parce que
il s'appelait Ramza et que il a dit euh
apparemment les gens voulaient pas le
prendre comme comme chef d'équipe c'est
ça absolument ouais oui et donc quoi
c'est ça qui a été mal perçu mais bon
vous aviez fait déjà d'autres sorties
avant voilà qui aurait pe être mal perçu
mais je pense que c'est multifactoriel
en fait déjà cette personne est soutenue
par beaucoup de groupes parce que B j'ai
fait j'ai fait mes recherches aussi j'ai
fait des recherches pardon aussi de mon
côté et des noms sont ressortis euh que
je ne dévoilerai pas parce que c'est pas
c'est pas à moi de le faire mais des
groupes quand même assez virulents qui
défendent notamment le H a l' il a l'air
hyper sympa il est venu il était oui non
mais je je je peut-être certainement
mais en tout cas on on a découvert que
c'était des groupes qui étaient quand
même pour le Hamas donc il défendent un
groupe terroriste et j'ai reçu plein de
messages avant même que tout tout cela
sorte j'ai reçu plein de
messages du type on va te faire tomber
tu vas crever tu on ne te verra plus
jamais à la télé on a ton adresse on
t'attend en bas de chez toi tu es qu'une
salle juif une salle Arch voilà les les
messages que je reçois depuis de jours
mais bon je garde le sourire quand même
parce que je je suis dans cette émission
le le weekend et ça ne donne beaucoup
d'espoir pour la suite ahah oui bah vous
serez avec nous d'ailleurs le weekend
prochain maître c'est qu'est-ce quelles
vont être les quelles vont être les
actions parce que B car dit que c'est
pas elle forcément vous allez faire vous
allez faire quoi une action contre qui
là une action contre X puisque pour
l'instant nous ne savons pas quels sont
les auteurs et nous allons les
identifier ou faire en sorte qu'il soit
identifié le plus rapidement possible
mais mais je crois qu'auudelà du fait de
savoir si c'est un compte qui
véritablement lui appartenait ou pas il
a le contexte donc il y a pas de raison
d'en douter le problème c'est le
problème du
harcèlement ce harcèlement sur sur
Internet au travers des réseaux sociaux
est devenu une véritable play et je
crois que personne ne se rend compte des
conséquences psychologiques et physiques
que peut avoir ce type de harcèlement à
l'égard de ceux qui en sont victimes moi
en fait je me demande ce que les gens
attendent pour réagir pour qu'il y ait
plus de signalement parce que à Cha fois
on réagit quand il y a un suicide quand
quelqu'un meurt et je pense que j'espère
que que cette histoire qui est pour moi
une histoire mineure c'estotique pour
vous c'est anecdotique c'est totalement
anecdotique anecdotique pardon c'est la
place de Jean-Michel mer c'est normal
qu'on embrasse d'ailleurs qui qui m'a
fait un joli compliment ah oui c'est
vrai ça ça m'a refait mon weekend ah oui
je me suis j'ai regardé la vidéo en Bou
ou c'est vrai qu'il a dit vous étiez
très jolis très syp vous embrasse vous
oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a Mo j'ai une
question à est plus chiant non non mais
j'ai j'ai une question j'ai une question
franche à vous poser en 2012 et lorsque
vous êtes cégienne dans les Yvelines je
crois dans un établissement public vous
dites vous-même j'ai lu des interviews
qu'à cette époque- là vous reprochez à
vos parents de vous avoir donné un
prénom européen que vous êtes poursuivi
frappé notamment par des Arabes moi ma
question là vous démantez que ce compte
Facebook vous appartiennent moi une
piste que je suis c'est qu'à ce
moment-là comme vous êtes harcelé vous
voulez donner des gages et donc du coup
et donc du coup vous vous protégez en
quelque sorte en faisant ces
publications sur Facebook pour dire
regardez j'ai beau avoir un premier
prénom européen je suis avec vous je
suis contre Israël est-ce que ça c'est
une P à explorer a ça aurait pu être le
cas mais malheureusement ou bien
heureusement ce n'est pas le cas parce
que en réalité j'ai fait une partie de
ma scolarité dans les iines parce que
mes parents avaient une maison dans la
vallée de Chevreuse mais j'ai été
transférée dans plein d'établissement
parce que j'ai subi beaucoup de
harcèlements mais on peut appeler mes
parents j'ai toujours é élevé dans
l'amour de tous et j'ai j'ai pas enfin
c'est ce n'est pas moi je peux pas
honnêtement je peux pas défendre une
personne que je ne connais pas ce n'est
pas moi oui voilà il y a une autre pour
moi la réelle problématique c'est pas t
le compte Facebook parce que tu l'as dit
bah Carla on sei parce qu'on se connaî
tu l'as dit tu avais 12 gens à cette
époque même si c'était même si c'était
réellement toi en réalité je m'en fiche
c'était des histoires c'était des
gamineries mais la problématique
aujourd'hui c'est ce que tu défends non
mais la problématique aujourd'hui c'est
ce que tu défends c'est c'est ce que tu
dis qui pose problème aujourd'hui on
t'attaque pour ton amour de la France je
reçois les mê m insultes que toi
systématiquement minsul de Hary de cabur
de buoun on en a discuté t pas les mêmes
insultes finalement toi et moi on est
passionnément français et on nous le
reproche donc aujourd'hui c'est pas tant
le compte facebook qui pose problème
c'est tes positions je te crois tu dis
que c'est pas ton compte même c'était
ton compte tu avais 12 ans peut-être que
tu aurait plaidé l'erreur de jeunesse et
ça aurait été compréhensible moi je
excusé lui vous l'aurez compris bah car
il veut surtout V
pécho s'app B non ça a été l'un des
premiers à me soutenir et je cétait Bay
Carlos pourquoi pas mais Carl
il est drôle il est drôle franchement il
est drôle on l'adore on l'adore oui mais
tu peux pas dire que des publications
antisémites c'est des GAM même ans à 10
an moi j'ai envie de vous croire
évidemment mais est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même que il y a
plusieurs photos al je crois que c'est
pas toute la même fille mais il y a
certaines photos d'une jeune fille qui
vous ressemble énormément est-ce que
c'est possible mais on va pas on va pas
trouver toutes les photos des Kabiles et
dire que c'est moi non mais la
ressemblance est vraiment
pas est- vous sa pourquoi pas bah non
moi j'ai été élevé en fait moi j'aime
pas moi ce qui me fait vraiment mal dans
cette histoire c'est l'image que mes
parents vont avoir je viens je viens
d'un milieu je viens d'un très bon
milieu peut-être mais c'est pas moi je
viens je viens je viens d'un milieu très
bien j'ai été très bien éduqué j'ai été
éduqué dans l'amour du catholicisme et
honnêtement qu'on m'affilie à cette
personne ça me dérange et et encore une
fois je reprends les les les propos de
Redwan le le vrai problème n'est pas là
c'est ce harcèlement que je subis parce
que je dis que j'aime la France mais
mais qui c'est est-ce qu'on sait qui
c'est du coup mais des recherches vont
être
faites si vous pouz juste me rendre un
petit service euh c'est Radwan et Ran
non mais baissé c'est trompé parce que
c'est baissé bah il y a Carla allez
euh merci euh ça ça vous ça vous ça vous
quand même ça vous peine tout ça ou bien
vous dites ça y est on va savoir c'est
pas moi j'ess j'essaie d'être forte
parce que je me dis qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
la la chance de pouvoir être entre
guillemets médiatisé de pouvoir parler
donc j'ai envie d'être forte pour les
les victimes qui subissent ça tous les
jours et de leur donner une voix et pour
ça j'ai pas le droit d'être triste donc
je vais de l'avant et ils n'auront pas
Maine oui maître dire quelque chose j'ai
pas j'ai pas davantage d'éléments à
apportter si ce n'est que je constate
tout de même que facebook serait le seul
espace dans lequel il n'y aurait pas de
droit à l'oubli combien même ce serait
Carla qui serait derrière cette photo ce
qui n'est pas le cas hein je dis pas
qu'elle le reconnaît mais on a tous le
droit à l'oubli pourquoi Facebook serait
le seul endroit où pendant
mais à qui viendrait-il à l'idée de
reprocher quoi que ce soit un enfant de
11 ans non
mais je prendre un autre exemple on
avait eu le à l'époque de la
starac était aussi très jeune elle
s'était faite sortir de la
St maîre dans vos propos et il y a quand
même une sorte de prudence et comme vous
êtes avocat vous pesez vos mots quand
bien même et si c'était elle est-ce que
vous êtes vraiment persuadé que ce n'est
pas elle moi je n'ai pas de piste
contrairement à vous j'ai des hypothèses
et je prends des hypothèse de travail ce
n'est ni des certitudes ni des vérités
la vérité judiciaire elle sortira le
moment venu et et je n'ai aucun doute en
tant qu'avocat conseil que cette vérité
judiciaire sera conforme à la vérité que
cette jeune femme est en train de vous
développer vous avez une question à
poser à ba car vous moi je vous sens
très hésitante sur le sujet je vous le
dis franchement bah je sens que vous
fluctuez que vous essayez de trouver
peut-être une solution ah non j'ai
aucune solution je vous dire non mais je
mais Mo moi je trouve ça dommage parce
que vous attaquez une victime ça fait ça
fait 2 jours que je subis toutes ces
insultes et moi je vous demande je vous
demande de me croire parce que c'est
c'est simplement la vérité et ça se voit
très bien les preuves sortiront ça c'est
certain j'ai j'ai beaucoup de preuves
vous pouvez compter sur moi et qu'on les
aura en fin de semaine dans l'émission
bah je vais tout faire pour oui parce
que c'est important pour moi parce que
jeéis en train de remplir le
conducteur voilà B va très bien oui
dernière une dernière question ou bien
c'est bon ah je pense que d'une certaine
manière on cherche aussi à viser bah
cyrilna et tout poste tu as fait
beaucoup de plateaux avant ça tu pass et
comme par hasard ça s auourd'hi j'ai
reçu beaucoup de messages comme ça de
TPMP boycotte on va tous les démonter un
Parin et C et d's des années qu'on
entend ça et d'ailleurs même mes
collègues Juliette labance
julienou BR brille
BR calme-toi s'il te
plaît ai je pense c'est ce que je disais
en prule c'est vrai que ce qui est fou
c'est que vous avez fait multitud de
plateau c'est quand vous êtes avec moi
qu' a des choses comme ça qui sortent
mais au contraire voulez que je vous
montre ça montre la puissance de nos
émissions non il y a vraiment des raid
numériques aujourd'hui il y a une
organisation vraiment et ça faut le dire
il faut démanteler ses organisations
parce que ça peut faire beaucoup de
dégâts nous aussi je me rappelle il
avent lancé le boycot TPMP on faisait 2
millions tous les soirs donc continuer
franchement toutçon on est là en fait
quoiainten exactement vous serez donc
avec moi samedi et dimanche prochain et
je voudrais souligner une dernière chose
c'est la violence des insultes et la
teneur de ces insultes qui sont à la
fois des insultes antisémite une sale
juive des insultes contre les archies
c'est une Archie des insultes contre les
Arabes c'est les Arabes des insultes
contre les Algériens enfin tout y passe
mais on voit qu'il y a une détestation
de l'autre une détestation de la
différence qui est juste insupportable
ça on faire autrement tant que Kell dit
et comme Kelly dit souvent l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux tant qu'il y
aura l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux
vous vous ferez tout le temps insulter
on se fera tout le temps insulter une
émission elle en a fait 50 100 200 des
émissions mais est-ce qu'elle a déjà
fait une émission qui a fait un million
jamais là tu as fait des émissions qui
qui fait 1 million je peux te dire la
semaine prochaine tu te feras encore
insulter c'est pour ça que je souhaite
rester tu souhait rester dans l'émission
tu V rest dans l'émission mais arrête de
regarder peut-être les commentaires par
que chaque fois très
sympaèsci merci B car merci maîre
d'avoir été avec on va se retrouver dans
un instant